uh and then we got codas season one okay
do you think code gas still deserves the
popularity yeah that that I got that I'm
honestly kind of shocked that it's not
higher it must have fallen recently uh
as less people probably get into it yeah
yeah I mean it's pretty old right now
yeah go to the uh yeah where is it at on
this list uh yeah it was 19 no no it it
went down did it yeah went down go back
up yeah it's 21 Yeah well yeah because
it's
right yeah yeah um I think I'm trying
I'm trying to think would I how much how
much is this Nostalgia talking oh I have
I have an un unbridled amount of
nostalgia for the show I this oh this
show just makes me feel happy when I see
it just such a good time it was like it
was like Peak like Xbox era to and I'm
like yeah when I watch I would say I
would say if I had to say anything I
think the only thing that is not aged
well with code gas is potentially the
visuals and like the character designs
it is very mid 2000s looking I love it I
love the fu that's the thing though it's
it's very like uh it's very like uh
divisive on like some I've heard some
people say like the visuals for codas
are amazing I've heard a lot of people
say they don't like the visuals for code
gas um but in terms of like how the
story was written and you know all of
the great things that made Kia such a
great story I think it's still holds it
was the first time I had to start like
checking my doors were shut before I
watched it cuz there would just be
random shots also the that was that was
uh Season Two Season Two just got
randomly way more horny than SE I like
hold on why am I also I will say the
blatant Pizza Hut ads uh in the middle
of each episodes were a bit weird even
back then all right all right I I I got
to say this okay I'm not sure code gas
is as good as we remember it all right
100% 100 I have I have rewatched it
right and you know we we we all Remember
That season 2 [__] mess right season
one though perfect perfect show in my
mind
almost perfect shot is that one episode
with the cat I was going to okay okay
there one episode with the cat do we
remember the Cat episode I remember do
we remember the whole uh ma Arc yeah
that was weird too I don't remember that
you wiped it from your M you WIP I might
have wiped it from my memory do you
remember when this other random guy with
a gas just kidnapped nanal and [__]
with and I was just like that was a
thing that happened and oh my God never
I think I guess I did wipe that from my
memory holy [__] yeah I do remember that
yeah I remember rewatching uh code GS
with Sydney like a few years ago uh cuz
she'd never seen it and she still
[__] loves the ending and everything
but I think watching it in modern days
you forget that there are maybe filler
is not the no I think it is filler but
there there is a lot of things there's a
lot of Random Encounters a lot of bloat
and also there is this point that I
don't know why I thought this was like a
[__] genius plot twist when I watched
this when I was like 17 or whatever um
but if you remember the end of there was
something that happened at the end of
season it's nearly a 20 year old show I
think it's F there is this point where
code gas had ended it's it solved all
his conflicts like euphemia was going to
be like hey it's okay I'm going to give
up the throne or whatever I can't
remember the exact thing but I remember
all of like the conflicts had been
solved and then Louch just
goes like if I had hypothetically told
you to go murder everyone yeah that was
so [__] funny if I just
hypothetically told you to go murder
everyone you do it and then out of like
sheer coincident he had awoken a second
gas and I'm just like I I remember
watching this as an nult I was just like
huh that feels kind of bullshitty
doesn't it kind of feel
shoe must have been like ain't no way
but like now I probably like I'd watch
it be like that's [__] dumb he's got
two whenit he said water euphemia at the
perfect time and she starts murdering
and now the plot continues and then
there's a season two now yeah that is
that is kind of weird yeah yeah yeah um
so yeah no maybe I I think Nostalgia is
carrying this to me one I think I think
I like it I still think it has the best
ending in anime
period I just think that if it aired
nowadays probably we'd be calling out
some of its let's say you
inconsistencies inconsistencies even
with season one uh Tora yeah I'm happy
with Tor at this PO I think it's my
favorite romance anime I I prefer golden
time
golden you're a real
one with you guys you we talking if
we're talking if we're talking romance
shows from the same author golden time I
think I always forget about Golden time
I think golden time is my favorite
romance anime of all time episode I
think I even said and I I say this fully
acknowledging that uh ghost banry was a
thing that I would like to for my memory
do you remember ghost
bannery good let's I have to rewatch
let's let's keep it that do you not
remember so we agree that we like this
spot but we swap it with golden time I
would swap toor with gold you think like
23rd for Golden time is Chill uh wait
why do I recognize this show that's
golden time this is golden time oh so
ghost banry was a side plot that uh is
it in the anime was yes oh my God I do
remember this cuz it was so [__] we had
just wiped the side plot from all of our
memories and this is the one blight
that's bringing down golden time for me
a what is that H hter edit I do remember
feeling
like I do remember feeling the [__]
cult thing was weird but I liked it I
don't know I I I I think I think let's
continue with the list we like golden
time
golden this is the violin why you're
line in April 24 for God's sake you I
hit
look at this rezero title what the [__]
can you can you read
that very good or rezero for short uh
okay y l in April I I have a bias
towards the show because I love shows
about music and as someone who did
classical piano like the soundtrack to
it is [__] awesome and I think it did
a lot of really good things uh the
ending was a bit whack I will say it
wasn't the ending it was halfway through
halfway through it was halfway through
which part it was like episode 14 I
think I don't remember okay I I I will I
will tell you this Jory because I really
really liked your line April and I
thought I I really [__] like the
music aspect of that um and then at some
point it just felt like it just gave up
on that aspect and was just and it was
like the writer thought hey this isn't
sad enough seeing someone deal with
their trauma of rediscovering music we
need we need [__] cancer or some [__]
we need a real death yeah and that to me
uh after that tal shift that I I kind of
like just checked out because it almost
felt I yeah it almost felt like a little
bit too forced where I was really
emotionally invested in uh I can't
remember his the main character's name
of like falling in love or rediscovering
his love for music and all the trauma
that he went through I was like really
emotionally invested in that I felt
super sad and super happy when seeing
him perform again um and then they just
gave when he hears the music again for
the first time like that scene is
gorgeous that made cry like a
[__] maybe I'll watch it someday
probably not cuz it's about
music yeah and then uh and then it kind
of went a completely different direction
about halfway through is this your way
of kind of saying maybe it doesn't
deserve to be in the top 25 I think it's
a little overrated yeah I think I think
think it's a top 50 not a top no yeah I
think it did a lot of good things uh but
again like online I feel like it fumbled
the bag okay fair enough which is
interesting because I remember reading
somewhere that apparently uh Oda the
Creator one piece he's he named y Li in
April as the one manga he wish he wrote
oh [__] yeah and I'm like no way ain't
no way that would have been a very
different show for if you had written it
next upo season one um I'm kind of
impressed how much rezer how much of an
impact rezero had considering not much
has happened in anime yet I feel like
we're just at the start of a journey
yeah and it's releasing way too slowly I
had a really fun time watching season
one yeah me too I I very liked it too
because it was very It Was a Very Fresh
concept and I felt like they explored
the uh return uh when you die you return
I they explored it in a really fun way
and in such like I feel like other shows
would be too scared to do what it did
and I really liked it I liked it a lot
it was fun yeah the side character is uh
sub lose me a bit though uh yeah that's
about it yeah yeah I mean also he's
cringe which is great cuz he learns to
not be cringe that's that's the he's a
true gamer he literally the gamer that
we needed where like kto is should
always cringe he literally dies from
cringe yeah
yeah um so I I think oh man it's so
tough cuz would you put in 25 I feel
like it's it's it's rezero is is still
so new almost rezer is cooking uh it's
still it's still in the oven I feel like
it's not done watching season 2 kind of
reminded me of watching attackman Titan
season 2 where you felt like oh they're
cooking something scratching yeah I'm
not sure what they're cooking but I'm
starting to smell it I'm star to even
like season three season 3 out no it's
not out only season two it's about to
come out that was season two That season
we've only had two seasons yeah that's
[__] season two felt like it was just
buildup it was yeah exactly and I was
like and when it ended I was like
huh yeah so I think season 3 is going to
be the real determiner uh to me but come
on man there's only so much R
merchandise we can push and come on bro
where where is it where is season 3 uh
it's airing next year I think wait
really yeah yeah oh yeah right we
watched the we watch the trailer
together con yeah dude I mean you
announced it Conor I know I did I did
announce it I I mean what's crazy to me
is that they must have unlimited
money this this show the amount of REM
merch they must have sold is appreciate
the fact that they're not rushing this
[__] out either they're cooking and I I
will let them cook as long Wu
penetration uh in the market is in we
haven't seen this kind of wfu
penetration uh don't say Wu penetration
Wu penetration in the market of waifus
yeah we have we have
ARA no REM REM [__] bodies also uh
are you you think so I think REM REM
bodies Asal in terms of like popularity
yeah no I think when s on line came out
was [__] everywhere AR ARA started
the trend REM just wrote thate that
wave arsa started the boring
vanilla thank you thank you and then
perfected
ITA didn't earn it bro Ran So Rim could
walk oh my gosh I will stand by that I I
man I don't feel like I feel like it's
going to cook so hard like you said that
I don't want to put it in 25 cuz I feel
like it's going to it's going to climb
but right now I just don't want to put
it anywhere I don't think I I would put
yeah it's hard to place I don't think I
would put it in my top 50 right now it's
definitely hard to place oh we are we
comparing ASA to R okay well while you
do that what's the next one just so we
can have a look uh the next one is Nori
norami at 27 is [__] insane to me I
think the opening is openings are
amazing the opening is doing a lot of
heavy lifting cuz that opening was so
goddamn popular and also also it was
another one of those shows where it was
everyone's thumbnail or everyone's
profile picture
[__] the guy the main guy from
norami um it was always you'd go on any
online website everyone had norami as a
profile picture yeah I was mostly Tumblr
though wasn't it tumblr Tumbl I'm
feeling like Tumblr seeing Tokyo Ghoul
and seeing norami I'm like damn Tumblr
did a lot of heavy lifting norami also
had like a lot of style and the time it
came out I think it was it it it was
quite unique at the time it came out I
yeah admittedly I I did I did have a lot
of fun watching orami season 1 uh
especially uh just because you know it
was just such a fun light-hearted you
know you know really aesthetic show as
well but like just it wasn't the most
interesting or compelling in terms of
story and then norami season 2 just
started to [__] drag on was was this
popular in Japan uh I believe so yeah
this is like I watched norami and I'm
like this was a fine show that I almost
have no opinion of and then I see it the
27th most popular and I'm like why how
did this happen why this show tot why
the [__] like what about norami stood
out to get this popular I I literally
have no idea it it's like it it's not a
bad show but I just it's just
uninteresting I don't even remember much
about it yeah the only thing I
remember wait so that's comparing ASA to
Ram what time period is that this is 200
uh past five years past five years yeah
I mean ASA fell off yeah ASA did fell
off but what like what about when how
what what was the peak when ARA just
kind kind of launched compared to the
peak of when REM I think Peak REM would
have been season one right so like 2011
okay so norami I don't even think I put
it in my top 100